He likes to pass the ball more
when he drives with his left.
And I'd prefer him to pass
than to shoot or score.
What's up guys,
Jrue Holiday here.
I'm going to take you
guys through my film session.
The break down.
Just to show you guys what
I do on a day-to-day basis
against the best
players in the world.
And why I'm the best
defender in the league.
Let's go.
What's hard about Steph
is he's super quick.
He's really quick,
really shifty.
We know how he can
get that shot off you.
So this, again
for me, it kind of
becomes like a long
distance track meet.
Where one of us are
going to get tired,
and it's not going
to be me first.
We already know that I'm staying
with Steph no matter what.
I get hit by a screen,
fight through the screen.
Over the top, underneath, but
most of the time over the top.
Because I can stay closer
to him and possibly
run him off the 3-point line.
At this point, I'm
just attached to him.
I'm stronger than him.
So I feel like I just try
to be physical with him.
And I don't want to give them
any room to get comfortable.
Don't let him just go
whichever way he wants to go.
And as they're doing
that dribble handoff,
I get my hand on the ball.
There's also another term
that we use, is called
"on an island."
So if I have Steph by myself
and he's in the corner.
And it's just me and him.
I'm "on the island" with Steph.
And usually, when
you're on that island,
somebody from behind you has
to communicate and tell you
what's going on.
So I crowd him because I
don't want him to shoot 3,
I don't want him give him space.
And then I kind of send
him in one direction.
You can see my right
foot is up at the top
of that 3-point line.
And I'm kind of giving
him that baseline drive,
knowing that my helper
is going to be there.
And then being able to
just kind of reach in
and knock that
ball out of bounds.
I didn't know the exact metrics.
But I also know for
us to win the game,
he's going to have
to really fight.
That's cool, that
even just here,
being able to get
that on record.
Just like how much you
pressure up on somebody.
And these are
professional athletes.
And they're best way to do it.
That's why they're in the
NBA and they make this money.
Dame is called "Logo
Dame" for a reason.
It's not easy to guard
somebody up that high.
That's where I hear a
lot of my teammates.
And what's going on,
if there's a screen,
which way to send him.
I'm already picking him
up close to half court.
The screen comes up, so
they communicate the screen.
I get underneath the screen
because the big man is up.
Four, five, maybe even six
feet above the 3-point line,
which Dame is capable
of shooting that.
But I get underneath so
that he doesn't split.
He doesn't try to dribble back
and split between me and him.
You see I kind of cut him off.
And then I keep
him at that angle.
So that he has one way to go.
I would prefer the ball
out of Damian's hands.
And you see Steph, Dame,
Trae Young, Luka, LeBron.
You see these guys
shoot from half court.
You see a big shot
like that go in,
and that could really spark
something in the score.
Defense is hard.
I mean like Boston,
where you have Kemba.
Loves to shoot the 3, but
also can get to the basket.
You have Jason, who is a
really good, damn near great, one-on-one player.
You have Jaylen Brown.
So all them, I view
them differently.
It's corner fill.
And you're not supposed
to leave corner fill.
Our philosophy,
don't leave corner
fill because that's one of
the best shots in the league.
I mean, guys make that
with our eyes closed.
I ended up being
late to the close-up.
Which, at this point, I'm
thinking, "I messed up.
Let me try to run
him off the line."
So I overshoot it.
And I try to get
on his left side
to try to make him
go down the line,
knowing that my helper's there.
Kemba to go up against somebody
like Brook, who's seven feet.
That's going to be
a difficult shot.
Jason, I feel like
I'm quicker than him.
So I usually try to
pressure up on him.
For one, he probably has
three or four inches on me.
He does a nice little crab
dribble to a step-back.
My momentum is forward.
I also know he's going to
take the step-back shot.
And I'm going to just
contest the best that I can.
That's kind of
where my mind goes
when I try to guard guys
who are prolific scorers.
To know that like you can
pressure up on somebody,
and still do a great job with
them is y'all just really making me feel good.
You know, out here, I should be
a Defensive Player of the Year.
Kids need to learn defense, man.
It's fun.
Kind of give you my
insight on defense.
And what it takes.
You got to start
locking people up, man.
It's the way to go.
Get under the skin.
Stop them defensively, man.
I love it.